>>> WE BEGIN IN DARKNESS, THEN A
SINGLE SPARK.
AND CHANGE RIPPLES THROUGH THE
WORLD.
THE SEEDS AND
THE SOIL SEEK
LIGHT.
SPLITS INLI TWO, THE MIND PULSE
WITH KNOWLEDGE.GE.
TODAY WE KNOW SO MUCH.
WE HAVE PRACTICED THE CODE OF
LIFE, CO GLIMPSED TO THE BIRTH
EXPOSED AMENITIES AND YET, FAR R
MORE  REMAINING THAN DARKNESS.S.
MOST OF THE UNIVERSE IS OF
UNKNOWN SUBSTANCE.
OUR MINDSSUBS ARE A MYSTERY TO .
IN THIS DARKNESS, ALL WE HAVE IS
OUR IDEAS.
SO LET US TEND THEIR FLAMES ES
UNTIL THEY GROW AND SPREAD
EXPANDING CIRCLES OF
ENLIGHTENMENT, SPARKS OF
CREATION.
>> TONIGHT, LIVE FROM
HANGER ONE
IN NASA IN SILICON VALLEY, THE
BRIGHTEST STARS FROM THE WORLDSO
OFRLDS SCIENCES, TECHNOLOGY ANDD
HOLLYWOOD ARE GATHERED TO AWARD
OVER $25 MILLION FOR EXCELLENCEE
IN LIFE, SCIENCE, MATHEMATICS,
AND PHYSICS.
THIS IS THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE,I
SCIENTISTS CHANGING
THE WORLD.
PLEASE WECOME THE  YOUR HOST MO
FREEMAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> WELCOME TO THE BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZEEAKT CEREMONY.REMO
LET'S TAKE A JOURNEY BACK TO THE
1600s TO BACK CELEBRATE A BIRTH
OF A PERSON BUT THE BIRTH OF AN
IDEA.
ITI BEGAN AS A FAINT NOTION ANDA
FEW BRAVE MINDS AT THE FOREFRONT
WAS A MATH PROFESSOR IN ITALY
NAMED  GALLALAO.ALAO.
BUT HE WAS NOT ALONE.
ANOTHER FEW BRAVE MINDS SHARED
THAT REVOLUTIONAY NOTION.N.
IT GREW STRONGER AND IT BEGAN TO
SPREAD.
IDEA WAS SIMPLE, TO DISCOVER THE
TRUTH YOU MUST QUESTION
EVERYTHING.
EVERY
EXPLANATION YOU EVER HAVE
BEEN TOLD FORN WHYATI THINGS ARS
THEY ARE, AND NOT MERELY
QUESTION IT BUT CRITICIZE IT.
TRY TO DISPROVE IT.
TEST IT ON THE WORLD.WO
IF IT FAILSR THE TEST, THROW IT
AWAY.
THINK OF A
NEW EXPLANATION, THEN, THEN
QUESTION THAT EXPLANATION IN IN
YOUR MISSION TO GET CLOSER TO
THE TRUTH.
AND THAT IDEA IS HOW WE GOT
HERE, IS HOW SO MANY OF YOU ARE
HERE TONIGHT WITH US.
SO WE'RE SEPARATED BY MOUNTAINS
AND OCEANS IS HOW WE LIT UP THE
WORLD, WALKED ON THE MOON.
SCIENCE IS NOT MERELY A TOPIC IN
A TEXTBOOK.
SCIENCE, SCIENCE IS A WAY OF
THINKING THE MOST POWERFUL ONESS
WE EVER DREAMED OF, POWERFUL BUT
FRAGILE.
GALLALO LIVED OUT ON HOUSE
ARREST.
IMAGINED STAR SYSTEMS BEYOND OUR
OWN WAS BURNED AT THE STAKE.
SO THEY ARE LONG GONE, THEIR
IDEAS BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, THEIR
IDEAS, ALL IDEAS ARE NOT  NUTUR.
WE MUST HONOR THOSE AND
REDEDICATE OURSELVES TO ALWAYS
QUESTIONING.ES
WETIO MUST HAVE THE COURAGE TO E
IN DOUBT AND IN DOING SO, WE
CELEBRATE WHAT ABOVE ALL ELSE
MAKES US HUMAN.
IMAGINING THE NEW.
ONCE EVERYTHING WAS NEW AND VERY
SMALL, THE UNIVERSE AND ALL IT
CONTAINS TODAY TOOK UP ABOUT THE
SPACE OF AY TO GRAPEFRUIT.
OVER THEGRAPE MILLENNIUM IT RELA
A BURSTS OF LIGHT.
13.8 MILLION YEARS LATER, A
PIONEERING TEAM OF SCIENTISTS
CAPTURE THAT LIGHT AND OUR
ORIGIN.
A SNAPSHOT OF THE DAWN OF TIME
AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO
RECEIVE THEIR REWARD.D.
THE FIRST OF THE BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZES, $3 MILLION GIFTS TO OUR
LAWYERS.
TO
PRESENT IT, WELCOME MULTIPLE PE
NOMINEE AND SCIENTISTS AND
INCUBATOR SAM ALTMAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> AS A NEURO SCIENTISTS THAT
PLAYS A NEURO BIOLOGIST ON TV, ,
IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO BE HERE  E
TONIGHT AMONG SO MANY BRILLIANT
MINDS AND STAND WITH THEM AND
HONOR A CAST THAT HAS EARNED THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IN
FUNDAMENTAL  PHYSICS.
>> FOR PHME, KEITH TO TECH
INVESTING IS HAVING A LONG TIME
ARRIVAL.
IF ONE DAY
CITIES WILL BE BUILT
FROMILL B SCRATCH BUT SOLAR ROB,
AND THEY WILL, THE SCIENTISTS
ARE WORKING WITH SC A TIME HORIZ
THATON  MAKES MINE LOOK KIND OF
LAME.
THEY ARE TAKING LONG
VIEW, PLUS,S,
THEY ARE LOOKING BACKWARDS.
>> THEY BUILT WBA MAPS, A NASA
MISSION THAT LOOKED AS  FAR BAC
IN TIME AS POSSIB TO SEE. SE
>> WITH WE MAP, WE SEE A PICTURE
OF THE UNIVERSE AS IT WAS
300,000 YEARS AFTER THE BIG
BANG.
WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE UNIVERSE'S
BABY PICTURE.
THIS ROOM, ENTIRE UNIVERSE IS
FILLED WITH THE LEFTOVER LIGHT
OF THE BIG BANG.
THERE ARE FEW HUNDRED PHOTONS
TRAVELING FOR 13.7 BILLION
YEARS.
THE OLDEST LIGHT.
>>
LIG LOOKING AT THE LIGHT, WE'RE
LOOKING BACK IN TIME.
NATURE HAS PROVIDED US WITH A
TIME MACHINE AND THAT IS THE
SPEED OF LIGHT.
>>L THAT RADIATION HAS STREAMED
ACROSS THE COSMOS TO US.
IT COMES TO US AND WE JUST
RECORD IT AS A PHOTOGRAPH
ESSENTIALLY.
>> WE
DESIGNED W MAP TO GO STUDY
THE TEMPERATURE FLUCTUATIONS OF
THIS LIGHT AND TO CHARACTERIZE
THE PATTERN ONCHARA THE SKY BEC
WE KNEW THAT THE PATTERN WOULD
UNRAVEL THE RECIPE FORAT THE TH
UNIVERSE.
>> YOUR MEASURING THE
RELATIVE VE
TEMPERATURE OF TWO POINTS OF THE
UNIVERSE, YOU'RE MEASURING IS
THAT ONE ONE 10,000th OR
100,000th OF A DEGREE HOTTER.
>> TO WORK WITH THEH LEVEL OF
PRECISION THAT WE WANTED ACROSS
SUCH LARGE AREAS OF SKY, WE
REALLY NEED TO GO TO SPACE AND
THAT'S WHY WE BUILT THE
SATELLITE.E.
THAT'S WHY WE BUILT W MAP. M
>> YOU SPENT MANY YEARS OF YOURR
LIFE  DESIGNING, TESTING,
BUILDING THIS INSTRUMENT.
>> YES, THE ONLYINS OTHER THING
COMPARES TO IS GIVING BIRTH.
IT WAS 1.5 MILLION MILES FROM
THE EARTH.EART
IT TOOK A YEAR OF DATA TO
ACTUALLY PUT TOGETHER A HIGH
QUALITY MAP OF THE SKY. SK
>> TO MY SURPRISE, WE SAW WHAT
WE EXPECTED TO SEE.E.
WITH W MAP, THE TOOLS WE HAD
WERE GOOD ENOUGH TO EXPLAIN WHAW
THE UNIVERSE LOOKED LIKE 13.8
BILLION YEARS AGO.
REALLY FOR THE FIRST TIME WITH
HIGH PRECISION BUT JUST LIKE
WITH A BABY, THE GENES ARE THERE
ALREADY.
ALL THE STUFF TO MAKE
IT INTO AN
ADULT ARE THERE BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVE ONE REGION THAT IS ONE
10,000th HOTTER THAN THE OTHER,
BY THE TIME YOU GET TO TODAY, Y,
THAT HAS GROWN TO BE A SUPER
CLUSTER OF GALAXY THAT CONTAINS
STARS, PLANETS AND US.
SOMEHOW WE SEEM TO HAVE DONE IT.
WE THINK WE UNDERSTAND THE
PHYSICS THAT HAPPENED IN THE
UNIVERSE'S FIRST MOMENT.
HERE IT IS.
THE INFANT UNIVERSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR
MAPS OF THE
UNIVERSE AND THE FLUCTUATIONS TA
THAT SEEDEDTI GALAXIES.
>>GAL THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IN
FUNDAMENTAL PHYSICS IS AWARDED
TO THE W MAP SCIENCE TEAM AND
LEADERS CHUCK BENNETT, GARY,
NORMAN, LIMON PAGE AND DAVID.
>> THE WDAVI IN W MAP STANDS FO
DAVID, ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF DS
THE  EXPERIMENT.
PROFESSOR WILKINSON EXP PASSED
BEFORE THE COMPLETION PAS BUT L
LONG ENOUGH TO SEE THE FIRST
DRAMATIC RESULT.
>> IT'S NOT AT ALL OBVIOUS THATT
WE HUMANS ON A TINY PLANET IN
THE ENORMOUS VASTNESS OF SPACE
COULD POSSIBLY ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE UNIVERSE AS A WHOLE,
BUT W MAP SURVEYED THE PATTERN
OF THE OLDEST LIGHT AND WE USEDD
THE LAWS OF PHYSICS TO DEDUCE CE
FROM THESE PATTERNS ANSWERS TO
OUR QUESTIONS.
THE RESULT IS RELATIVELY SIMPLE
BUT STRANGE.
ATOMS MAKE UP ONLY 5% OF THE
UNIVERSE.
DARK MATTER AND DARK ENERGY
DOMINATE.
SCIENCE HAS LET US
EXTEND OUR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE UNIVERSE TO FAR
BEYOND OUR PHYSICAL REACH.
THERE IS SO MUCH WE DO NOT O NOT
UNDERSTAND SUCH AS THE FIRST
MOMENTS OF THE UNIVERSE, SO
THERE WILL BE NEW BREAKTHROUGHSR
IN THE OUFUTURE.
THANK YOU.
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> CLIMATE CHANGE HAS BEEN A
THREAT BUT CARBON OUT OF THE AIR
AND STORE IT IN THE GROUND CAN
HARNESS THE POWER TO SAVE OUR
PLANET, WE'LL MEET A SCIENTIST
TRYING TO DO JUST THAT WHEN WE
RETURN.
SCIENCE IS CHANGING THE WORLD.
.
>>> WELCOME BACK TO THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE CEREMONY.
THIS IS MY SECOND YEAR HOSTING
THIS EVENT, PROVING ONCE AGAIN
THAT ALL ACTORS LOVE A GOOD
SEQUEL.
THIS YEAR BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE
CO-FOUNDER MARK ZUCKERBERG IS
AWAY TAKING A LITTLE FAMILY
BREAK BUT HE SENT US THIS
MESSAGE.
>> HEY, EVERYONE.
WE CREATED THE BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE TO CELEBRATE THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE GREATEST
MINDS, SCIENTISTS FUND MENTAL
PHYSICISTS AND MATHEMATICIANS.
PRISCILLA AND I ARE SORRY WE
CAN'T BE THERE TONIGHT TO
CELEBRATE WITH YOU BUT I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO CONGRATULATE
YOU FOR THE INCREDIBLE
ACHIEVEMENTS AND THANK YOU.
IT IS BECAUSE OF YOU WE CAN
IMAGINE A WORLD WHERE OUR
CHILDREN'S DISEASES CAN BE CURED
AND WE CAN REACH OUR FULL
POTENTIAL.
WE NEED INSPIRATION AND
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T FEEL THIS
WAY, WE ARE MAKING STEADY
PROGRESS TOWARD BUILDING A
BETTER FUTURE FOR EVERYONE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL OF YOU
AND MY DEEPEST THANKS FOR ALL
YOU DO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> A SEED GROWS TOWARDS
SUNLIGHT, THEN SPROUTS LEAVES TO
CATCH THE RAYS THAT ALLOW IT TO
THRIVE.
A PROCESS SO SIMPLE, A
3-YEAR-OLD CAN GRASP IT.
YET, ALL OF OUR CIVILIZATION
WOULD BE NOTHING WITHOUT IT.
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO THE
SCIENTISTS WHO WORKED OUT HOW IT
HAPPENS, WE HAVE A SCIENTIST OUT
NUCLEAR REGULATORY COMMISSION
AND CURRENT MISS USA AND JOINING
HER IS KEVIN SYSTRIM, THE
CO-FOUNDER AND CEO OF INSTAGRAM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR ANYONE WITH A STARTUP,
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU THINK A LOT
ABOUT THAT ALL SEEMS EASY UNTIL
YOU TRY TO DO IT YOURSELF.
THEN YOU REALIZE IT'S REALLY
COMPLICATED.
SHE HAD AN ANSWER ABOUT PLANTS
AND FROM IT SHE GLEAMED A
FUNDAMENTAL UNLING OF PLANT
GENETICS AND NOW USING GENETICS
TO SEE THE THREAT WE ALL FACE
FROM CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE IS A PLANTARRY
MORNING.
AS A SCIENTISTS, PIE JOB IS TO
-- MY JOB IS TO PREPARE FOR
MORNINGS.
HOW TO MINIMIZE THE FALLOUT AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
PIONEERING SCIENTISTS IS DOING,
BUT ON A GLOBAL SCALE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL TELL YOU
WHO ARE SCIENTISTS I DID MY
FIRST EXPERIMENT WHEN I WAS 4 OR
SOMETHING.
I WASN'T ONE OF THOSE KIDS.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHY I WAS A
LATE BLOOMER, BUT I JUST WAS A
LATE GLOOMER.
YOU HAVE TO KIND OF KEEP THAT
SORT OF AWE, YOU KNOW.
WHEN YOU HAVE AWE ABOUT SOME
PROCESS AND THEN YOU THINK OKAY,
HOW CAN THIS HAVE HAPPENED?
AN EXPERIMENT THAT I DID A LONG
TIME AGO THAT TURNED OUT TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT IN THE WAY WE
THINK ABOUT HOW PLANTS GROW AND
HOW THE ENVIRONMENT CAN COME IN
AND MODIFY THAT WAS AN EASIER
EXPERIMENT THAN PUTTING PLANTS
IN BROAD SPECTRUM WHITE LIGHT
VERSUS THE DARK IF YOU REALLY
WANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW PLANTS
GROW.
IN THE DARK A PLANT CAN FWROE
-- GROW FOR AWHILE.
IT'S A SEED IN THE GROUND AND
HAS TO GROW UP AND FIND LIGHT,
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE THE BIG LONG
STEM.
WE LOOK FOR PLANTS THAT DIDN'T
DO WHAT THE NORMAL PLANT WAS
DOING.
WE FOUND SEVERAL MUTANT PLANTS
LOOKED LIKE THEY HAD BEEN IN THE
LIGHT EVEN THOUGH THEY WEREN'T
IN THE LIGHT AND WE LOOKED FOR
PLANTS THAT WERE IN THE LIGHT
LOOKED LONGER MORE LIKE GUYS
GROWING IN THE DARK.
BY DOING THAT, WE ACTUALLY WERE
ABLE TO SHOW HOW PLANTS GROW.
IT'S A VERY RELEVANT QUESTION
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF GLOBAL
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I ACTUALLY THINK WE HAVE 100
YEARS LEFT ON THIS PLANET AT
MOST IF WE DON'T START CHANGING
THE WAY WE GROW PLANTS.
WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE AN IDEAL
PLANT, ONE THAT WOULD, YOU KNOW,
SEQUESTER CO 2 SO YOU HAVE LESS
GREENHOUSE GASES BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT PLANTS DO REALLY WELL.
THAT'S WHAT PHOTOSYNTHESIS IS.
IT TAKES THE CO 2 AND SUGARS.
WE'LL MAKE PLANTS BETTER AT
TAKING THE SUGARS AND STICKING
THEM DEEP IN THE SOIL AND I
THINK WE CAN DO THAT.
I'M WORKING ON SAVING THE WORLD,
THAT'S RIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR DISCOVERING HOW PLANTS
OPTIMIZE THEIR GROWTH,
DEVELOPMENT AND STRUCTURE TO
TRANSFORM SUNLIGHT INTO CHEMICAL
ENERGY.
>> OUR $3 MILLION BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE IS AWARDED TO
JOANNE CHORY.
>> SHE GROW UP AS ONE OF SIX
CHILDREN, FOUR OF THEM BOYS.
THEY TOUGHENED ME UP.
NO ONE AT WORK SAID ANYTHING
NEARLY AS MEAN AS THOSE GUYS.
>> OKAY, FOLLOW MY HANDS.
I'LL BE MOVING A LOT.
PLANTS ARE THE FOUNDATION OF ALL
LIFE ON EARTH, YET, WE ARE OFTEN
BLIND TO THEIR EXISTENCE.
THIS RECOGNITION OF THE
DISCIPLINE OF PLANT GWINNETT
TICKS IS MEANINGFUL AND FAR
REACHING AS OUR WORLD EDGES
CLOSER TO A CRISIS OF
SUSTAINABILITY.
I HOPE IT WILL BRING GREATER
AWARENESS OF THE IMPACT PLANTS
CAN HAVE OF THE QUALITY OF HUMAN
LIFE.
OUR CHILDREN AND GRAND CHILDREN
DEPEND ON THAT AWARENESS.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> WHAT DEFINES LIVING THINGS?
PERHAPS MOST CLEARLY IS THEIR
ABILITY TO REPRODUCE THEMSELVES
BUT HOW DO THEY DO IT?
WE DIVE DEEP INTO THE HEART OF
THE SOUTH TO FIND OUT WHEN WE
RETURN LIVE ON NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC.
>>> WELCOME BACK.
I WANT YOU TO IMAGINE A SINGLE
SAIL BOBBING IN AN ANCIENT SEA.
IT SPLITS IN TWO AND THE STORY
OF LIFE IS UNDERWAY.
A STORY WHOSE BEATS ARE THE
CONCEPT AND SPLITTING OF SAILS
BORN INTO TWO, TWO INTO FOUR, TO
CHILD INTO WOMAN.
TO INTRODUCE A SCIENTIST THAT
SPENT YEARS UNTANGLING THE
THREADS, WE HAVE TWO FILM AND
TELEVISION STARS WHO CLEARLY
LOVE TECHNOLOGY AND EACH OTHER.
SHE'S A GLOBAL GLOBE NOMINEE AND
HE'S WITH AIR B AND B, SPOTFY
AND UBER.
WELCOME MILA KUNIS AND ASHTON
KUTCHER.
>> ASHTON AND I ARE THRILLED TO
BE PART OF THIS SHOW, BUT THE
GREATEST SHOW ON EARTH IS WHAT
HAPPENS WITHIN US, AND BY US, I
MEAN WOMEN.
WHEN I WAS PREGNANT, I HAD THIS
APP THAT TOLD ME HOW BIG MY
DAUGHTER WAS, THE SIZE OF AN
AVOCADO AND GOT TOO BIG TO BE
COMPARED TO A FRUIT BUT --
THANKS, GUYS.
BUT THE APP TOLD ME WHAT WAS
GROWING AND WHEN.
THE HANDS, THE EYES, THE BRAIN.
THEN YOU REALIZE EVERY MOMENT
ALONG THE WAY REQUIRES THE
PERFECT SPLITTING OF DNA AND
SO --
>> I CAN CONFIRM THAT MILA WAS
TOTALLY OBSESSED WITH THE FRUIT
APP.
AND ACTUALLY SOMEONE HERE
TONIGHT PROBABLY INVENTED THE
U.I. FOR THAT SO THANK YOU.
THOSE WERE FUN NIGHTS.
AS OUR CHILDREN GROW UP, IT IS
TRULY AMAZING TO SEE WHAT IS
SHAPED BY THE MICROSCOPE
PROCESS, WHAT WE CAN SEE IS HOW
DELICATE AND HOW DIFFICULT THAT
PROCESS IS.
>> WE ALL GROW UP, YOU KNOW, AND
WE LISTEN TO THE TEACHER.
YOU EITHER HEAR SOMETHING OR YOU
READ SOMETHING AND YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT.
YOUR FIRST REACTION FROM SCHOOL
IS OH, WELL, I'M STUPID.
AFTER MANY DECADES OF FEELING
THIS, I REALIZE MOST OF THE TIME
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
THEMSELVES REALIZING THAT
SOMETHING DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THAT'S THE KEY THING, SOMETHING
IS OUT THERE BUT YOU'RE THE
FIRST PERSON THAT DOESN'T ACCEPT
THE CONVENTIONAL EXPLANATIONS
DON'T WORK.
THE HUMAN CELL IS CONTINUITY OF
CELLS DIVIDING AND PRODUCING TWO
NEW CELLS.
IT WAS A COMPLETE MYSTERY THAT
HAD BEEN DESCRIBED FOR 100 YEARS
HOW THE DNA, THE SISTER DNAs ARE
DISJOINED.
HOW DO YOU ENSURE ONE GOES TO
THE LEFT AND ONE GOES TO THE
RIGHT AND ONE DOWN THE MIDDLE.
THERE IS TWO METERS OF DNA.
HOW ON EARTH DOES THE CELL KNOW
WHICH TANGLED MESS OF DNA NEEDS
TO BE HELD TOGETHER?
IT REQUIRES THAT STEP TO IMAGINE
IF IT DID EXIST, YOU CAN NOW
EXPLAIN THINGS THAT CAN'T
OTHERWISE BE EXPLAINED.
I GOT BACK FROM A LONG CLIMBING
TRIP HAVING SPENT DAYS DEALING
WITH ROPES AND CLIPS AND I HAD
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT IDEA
OF MY ENTIRE CAREER.
YOU WANT TO ASSEMBLE THIS DNA
INTO ONE STRUCTURE AND THIS ONE
INTO A SEPARATE ONE.
EVEN THOUGH YOU SEPARATE FROM
THE PART, YOU HOLD ON TO THEM IN
CERTAIN PLACES AND WHAT WE
REALIZE IS THAT THEY ARE ALL
HELD TOGETHER BUT THE COHESIVE
RINGS.
AND THEN IT'S BROKEN OPEN AND
THIS GOES ONE WAY, THIS GOES THE
OTHER WAY AND THE TWO DNAs GO
TOWARDS THE SUN.
YOU THINK GOSH, SO THAT'S HOW IT
WORKS?
IT IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO
GET THE TRUTH.
YOU CAN'T EXPLAIN THE WORLD IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW.
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO IMAGINE
SOMETHING NEW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR REVEALING THE MECHANISM
THAT CHOSE THE SEPARATION IN
CHROME ZONES, NO BIG DEAL GUYS.
>> OUR NEXT BIG AWARD GOES TO
KIM NASMYTH.
>> WHEN HE'S NOT EXPLAINING
CHROME SOEMS OR CLIMBING
MOUNTAINS.
>> THE WORLD WE LIVE IN WAS
FORGED BY THE ENLIGHTENMENT
WHICH STRESSED REASON OVER
TRADITION.
NOW THE MEDIUM BY WHICH IDEAS
ARE EVALUATED HAS JUST UNDERGONE
A PROFOUND CHANGE.
AND THIS HAS BEEN ACCOMPANIED BY
A TENDENCY TO THINK BUT WHAT YOU
SAY MATTERS MORE THAN WHAT CAN
BE DEMONSTRATED.
MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
DISCOVERING THE TRUTH IS NOT
EASY BUT IMMENSELY REWARDING.
GETTING BACK TO THE FACTS IS
CRUCIAL IF WE ARE TO SURVIVE
LONG ENOUGH TO FIND OUT THAT WE
ARE NOT ALONE IN THIS UNIVERSE.
WE WILL THEN DISCOVER IF THE
LAWS OF BIOLOGY ARE AS UNIVERSAL
AS THOSE OF PHYSICS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> HOW MANY ALBERT EINSTEINS
HAVE COME AND GONE UNKNOWN
BECAUSE THEY LACK THE ABILITY TO
DESCRIBE THEIR OWN IDEAS?
SADLY, THE BRIGHTEST SPOT WILL
DIE BUT DOES NOT CATCH.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED NOT JUST
GREAT SCIENTISTS BUT GREAT
COMMUNICATORS THAT CAN TELL
NATURE'S STORY IN A WAY THAT
GRIPS US.
TO EXPAND THEIR CIRCLE OF
ENLIGHTENMENT TO ENCOMPASS
THOUSANDS.
TO INTRODUCE YOU INTO
COMMUNICATOR WELCOME JULIA
MAINER AND LILY COLLINS.
♪
>>> IN MY ADVOCACY FOR ANTI
BULLYING AND SELF-IMPROVESELF-I
THE BIGGEST GIFT A CHILD CAN
HAVE IS THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE.
KIDS DISCOVER WHO THEY ARE, THEY
CAN CHANGE THE ENTIRE CULTURE.
>> WE WANT TO BRING THE NEXT
GENERATION WITH BIG IDEAS IN
MATH AND SCIENCE AND PEOPLE WHO
KNOW HOW TO GIFT US, GIFT
THEMSELVES.
THIS WHY THREE YEARS AGO
TOGETHER WE HAVE A CHANCE AND
WITH SUPPORT, WE ESTABLISH THE
BREAKTHROUGH JUNIOR CHALLENGE.
A VIDEO COMPETITION FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
THE WINNER THIS YEAR IS
REMARKABLE SCIENCE COMMUNICATOR.
>> NOW IS A VERY, VERY GREAT
TIME TO LIVE FOR SCIENCE.
THERE ARE SO MANY UNKNOWN
QUESTIONS AROUND THE WORLD THAT
NEED -- THAT NEED ANSWERS.
>> EXACTLY WHAT NUMBER IS THIS?
SHE SAYS IT'S SIX.
SHE SAYS IT'S NINE.
SO WHO IS RIGHT?
IN MY VIDEO, ONE OF THE
REOCCURRING THEMES IS HOW I
APPLY PHYSICS THROUGH MY LIFE.
IT MAKES PEOPLE RELATE ON A MUCH
DEEPER LEVEL.
THE REALLY MIND-BLOWING LEVEL IS
OBSERVERS, THE DIFFERENCE
VERSION OF THE SAME REALITY AND
EVERY OBSERVERS FRAME IS VALID.
>> SHE HAS REALLY BRIGHT FUTURE.
WHAT MAKES HER SPECIAL IS THAT
SHE ASKS QUESTIONS BEYOND OUR
LESSON.
SOMETIMES SHE FINDS THE ANSWER
BY HERSELF.
SHE GOES BEYOND.
>> I WAS 14 AT THE TIME IN
EIGHTH GRADE.
WE WERE REALLY SURPRISED WHEN
SUDDENLY THE WATER CAME CRASHING
DOWN ON OUR WINDOWS, EVERYTHING
BROKE.
WE HAD TO RUSH.
THE PACIFIC OCEAN JUST CRASHED
INSIDE OUR HOUSE AND FILLED THE
ENTIRE HOUSE IN ABOUT THREE
MINUTES OR SO.
>> AFTER THE TYPHOON, EVERYTHING
WAS GONE.
SO WE HAVE TO START FROM
SCRATCH.
THAT WAS TOUGH.
HAVING NO SCHOOL FACILITIES AT
ALL.
>> IT'S GREAT HONOR FOR ME TO
HAVE -- TO HAVE A LAB PROVIDED
FOR THE SCHOOL.
I GET TO HELP PEOPLE TANGIBLY
THROUGH THIS LOVE AND IT FEELS
ESPECIALLY GREAT SINCE IT ALIGNS
WITH ONE OF MY BIGGEST ADVOCACYS
TO EXTEND SCIENCE EDUCATION TO
OTHERS.
ONCE WE COME TO UNDERSTAND
PHYSICS, WE GET DEEPER AND
DEEPER INTO UNDERSTANDING THE
UNIVERSE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE SKILLS I THINK
WOULD MAKE A BETTER SOCIETY.
PEOPLE THAT CAN THINK DEEPER
THAN WHAT IT IS AT FACE VALUE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> AND TONIGHT, WE HAVE EXPRESS
FOR HILARY.
JUST I LIVE.
>> PLEASE WECOME THE DIRECTOR
OF PHILIPPINES HIGH SCHOOL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
HILLARY, REMEMBER THIS SONG?
♪ THIS IS YOUR QUEST TO FOLLOW
THE STARS, TO REACH THE
UNREACHABLE STARS ♪
>> JULIE, YOU HAVE A PASSION FOR
EXCELLENCE, PURSUIT OF TRUTH AND
SERVICE TO THE NATION.
I CONGRATULATE YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY.
WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
YOUR DREAM IS NOW A REALITY.
LET YOUR STARS SHINE AND BE THE
BEST SCIENTIST AND EXPERT THAT
YOU CAN BE.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
>> FOR HER SHORT FILM,
RELATIVITY AND THE EQUIVALENCE
OF REFERENCE FRAME.
THE WINNER OF THE 2000
BREAKTHROUGH JUNIOR CHALLENGE
JULIA.
>> I ALWAYS LOOKED UP TO TWO
KINDS OF STARS, THOSE WHO SHINE
AT NIGHT AND CHIMING ABOUT THE
UNIVERSE.
THESE AMAZING SCIENTISTS INSPIRE
ME WITH THEIR GENIUS TO PURSUE
THE TRUTH.
I'M GRATEFUL THIS AWARD ALLOWED
ME TO BECOME A RISING STAR WITH
EVEN BIGGER DREAMS.
MAY THIS INSPIRE MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY MY DEAR
FILIPINOS TO LOOK UP AND BECOME
SCIENTISTS THEMSELVES, THE STARS
WE SHOULD ALL LOOK UP TO.
THANK YOU TO ALL THOSE WHO
SUPPORTED ME THROUGHOUT THIS
JOURNEY.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> MUSICAL WORLDS JOIN TOGETHER
WHEN RAP SUPER STAR WIZ KHALIFA
PERFORMS A ONCE IN A LIFETIME
VERSION OF HIS NUMBER ONE SMASH
HIT, SEE YOU AGAIN WITH CHINESE
SUPER STAR AND ACTRESS WHEN THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE CONTINUES.
.
>>> WELCOME BACK, THIS IS A
CELEBRATION OF SCIENCE AND AS WE
KNOW, EVERY CELEBRATION NEED'
MUSIC.
TO SHARE THAT MUSIC ARE THE
YOUNG DEBUT IN CHINESE "SEE YOU
AGAIN" HAS BEEN VIEWED ON
YOUTUBE OVER 3 BILLION TIMES
ACCOMPANIED BY THE STANFORD
EVERYDAY PEOPLE CHOIR, HERE ARE
NANA OU-YANG AND WIZ KHALIFA.
♪
♪ YEAH, WHO KNEW, ALL THE PLANES
WE FLEW, THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH THAT I WOULD BE STANDING
RIGHT HERE TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
ANOTHER PATH, I KNOW WE WOULD
LOVE TO HIT THE ROAD AT LAST,
SOMETHING TOLD ME IT WOULDN'T
LAST, LOOK AT THINGS DIFFERENT
SEE THE BIGGER PICTURE.
THOSE WERE THE DAYS, HARD WORK
FOREVER PAYS.
NOW I SEE YOU IN A BETTER
PLACE ♪
♪ HOW COULD WE NOT TALK ABOUT
FAMILY WHEN FAMILY IS ALL THAT
WE GOT ♪
♪ EVERYTHING THAT I DO, YOU WAS
STANDING BY MY SIDE AND NOW YOU
GOING TO BE WITH ME FOR THE LAST
RIDE ♪
♪
♪ FIRST YOU BOTH GO OUT YOUR WAY
AND THE VIBE IS FEELING STRONG
AND A SMALL TURN INTO A
FRIENDSHIP AND A FRIENDSHIP TURN
INTO A BOND AND THAT BOND NEVER
BE BROKEN AND THAT LOVE WILL
NEVER BE LOST ♪
♪ HEY, AND BROTHERS COME FIRST
AND THAT BOND THAT WILL BE
BROUGHT ESTABLISHED ON THEIR OWN
AND THAT REMEMBER ME WHEN I'M
GONE ♪
♪ HOW CAN WE NOT TALK ABOUT
FAMILY WHEN FAMILY IS ALL THAT
WE GOT ♪
♪ EVERYTHING THAT I DO YOU WAS
STANDING THERE BY MY SIDE AND
NOW YOU GOING TO BE WITH ME FOR
THE FIRST TIME ♪
♪ LET'S GO ♪
♪
♪ YEAH, YEAH, YEAH ♪
♪ WHAT ♪
♪
♪ BEEN A LONG DAY ♪
♪ YEAH ♪
♪ BUT I SEE YOU AGAIN ♪
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> WHEN WE RETURN, THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE CONTINUES
LIVE ON NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC.
>>> WELCOME BACK.
LET ME SAY THE YOUNG CHELEST UP
HERE IS 17 YEARS OLD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> MAKES ME FEEL STUPID.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DO NOT FLOAT AROUND IN EMPTY
SPACE.
THEY INHABIT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF THE BRAIN BUT IF THE BRAIN
STARTS TO FAIL, THESE IDEAS ARE
NOT JUST LOST TO THEIR CREATOR
BUT LOSS TO US ALL.
OUR NEXT SCIENTIST DESIGNED GENE
THERAPISTS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
THE DISEASES THAT ROB US OF
IDEAS, FEELINGS AND MEMORIES.
TO TELL US MORE WELCOME
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE AND GOGGLE
FOUNDER SERGEY BRINN AND
NOMINATED ACTRESS KERRY
WASHINGTON.
>> IN FEBRUARY THIS YEAR, TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS
THE WORLD TOOK PART IN THE MARCH
FOR SCIENCE.
IMAGINE THIS, THEY TOOK A STAND
FOR THE ENLIGHTENMENT VALUES OF
REASON, EVIDENCE, RESPECT FOR
THE TRUTH AND THIS IS NOT JUST A
MATTER OF PRINCIPLE, IT'S TRULY
A MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH
BECAUSE SCIENCE REMAINS THE ONLY
TOOL WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
DISEASES THAT AFFECT OUR BODIES
AND MINDS.
>> I JUST MET OUR HIM LAST NIGHT
AND HE WAS SO MODEST HE BRIEFLY
MENTIONED HIS DNA THERAPIES BUT
THAT TURNS OUT TO BE THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG OF HIS LONG LIST OF
SCIENTIFIC DISCOVERIES AND
FURTHER MORE, THIS NEW KIND OF
THERAPY HOLDS PROMISE FOR MANY
DIFFERENT DISEASES IN ADDITION
TO THE PRESENT TRIALS BEING
CONDUCTED IN HUNTINGTONS.
>> EACH YEAR ONE BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE IS AWARDED TO A SCIENTIST
THAT MADE SIGNIFICANT ADVANCES
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST NEURO
DEGENERATIVE DISEASES.
>> WHICH GENES ARE REALLY
DRIVING DISEASE?
YOU'D LIKE TO TREAT THE CELLS
DRIVING RAPID DISEASE
PROGRESSION SO WE THOUGHT HOW
CAN WE DO THAT?
THE NERVOUS SYSTEM ABSOLUTELY IS
AN INTERCONNECTED NEIGHBORHOOD.
VERY BIG CELLS THAT HAVE TO LIVE
FOR OUR LIFE SPANS.
THEY ARE NEVER REPLACED.
THEY NEED HELP.
THEY ARE SO HIGHLY INNER
CONNECTED THAT IN THE MAJOR
NEURO DEGENERATIVE DISEASES, THE
INITIATING VENTS MAY BE DISTANT
FROM WHERE THE FINAL FAILURE IS.
IN THE ONE THAT WE GOT STARTED
WITH, ALS, SOMETIMES CALLED LIEU
DISEASE, THE MUTANT GENE IS
EXPRESSED IN EVERY CELL IN THE
BODY AND IT DAMAGES NOT JUST THE
MOTOR NEURONS BUT CELLS THAT
SUPPORT THE HEALTH OF THE MOTOR
NEURONS.
CAN WE USE A DESIGNER DNA DRUG
APPROACH TO SILENCE THE BAD
GENE?
THE SOURCE OF APPROACHES HAD
BEEN TRIED NOT IN THE NERVOUS
SYSTEM BUT TISSUES AND FAILED
TIME AND TIME AGAIN AND THE
ATTEMPT TO PUT THEM INTO THE
NERVOUS SYSTEM SUCCEEDED.
WE INTRODUCED THE DRUG INTO THE
NERVOUS SYSTEM AND SHOWED THAT
WE COULD DELIVER IT ALMOST
EVERYWHERE IN AN EFFECTIVE WAY.
IN A DECADE WE'LL SEE MAJOR
CHANGES IN PATIENT THERAPY AND
OUTCOME.
I AM AN OPTIMISM AND ALWAYS
BEEN.
IT WILL HAVE MAJOR EFFECTS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR REVIEWING THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A TYPE OF INHERENTED ALS AND
MODELS OF ALS AND HUNTINGTON
DISEASE.
>> THE $3 MILLION BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE IS AWARDED TO DON
CLEVELAND.
>> DON CLEVELAND IS TRULY A
HIGH-FLYING THINKER.
THERE IS A LOT OF THINKING IN
AIRPLANES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> SCIENCE PROPELLED AMERICA TO
GREATNESS AND LEADERSHIP AND
SCIENCE IS CRUCIAL FOR AMERICA
TO MAINTAIN THAT GREATNESS.
I LEARNED THIS LESSON INITIALLY
FROM MY FATHER, A PHYSICS
PROFESSOR AND THEN I WATCHED HIM
SLOWLY DISABLED BY PARKINSONS
DISEASE, WHICH NATURALLY
MOTIVATED MY INTEREST IN NEURO
SCIENCE.
I SHARE THIS EXTRA ORDINARY
HONOR TODAY WITH MY LIFE THAT
ENABLED ME TO PURSUE A CAREER I
LOVE AND COLLEAGUES AND
TRAINEES.
TOGETHER WE HAVE USED SCIENCE TO
DECODE THE PATHWAYS THAT DEVELOP
RATIONAL THERAPIES OF DISEASES
OF THE NERVOUS SYSTEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> EVERY YEAR LIFE SCIENTISTS
CLAIM NEW GROUND IN THE BATTLE
AGAINST HUMAN DISEASES BUT THAT
BATTLE IS ON GOING AND ITS COSTS
REMAIN HEAVY.
TONIGHT WE PAY TRIBUTE TO SOME
GREAT MINDS TAKEN FROM US THIS
PAST YEAR.
RUBEN WAS BORN IN PHILADELPHIA.
SHE STARTED LOOKING AT THE SKY
AT THE AGE OF 10 AND SIMPLY GOT
HOOKED AT WATCHING STARS.
SHE CHANGED OUR CONCEPTION OF
WHAT THE UNIVERSE IS MADE OF.
HER OBSERVATIONS OF GALAXIES
CONFIRMED THAT MOST OF THE MASS
IN THE COSMOS IS THE MYSTERIOUS
SUBSTANCE KNOWN AS DARK MATTER.
WITH THIS DISCOVERY, MIRA RUBEN
TOOK HER PLACE IN ASTRONMY.
>> MERRIMAN WAS BORN IN TEHRAN
IN 1977.
SHE EXPLORED THE SURFACES.
HER FEARLESSNESS AND PERSISTENT
BROUGHT HER TO CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN BRANCHS OF MAN.
SHE WON THE BIELS MEDAL, THE
WORLD'S MOST PRESTIGIOUS PRIZE
FOR WOMAN UNDER 40.
THE FIRST WOMAN AND IRANIAN TO
WIN IT.
MIRIAM LEAVES US THE GIFT OF
NEWLY OPEN PATHS TO FUTURE
DISCOVERIES.
>> HONORING HER TONIGHT IS MARYA
M's HUSBAND.
♪
>>> EVERY HOUR, THE AVERAGE CELL
CREATES OVER 1 MILLION PROTEINS
THAT WE NEED TO LIVE, BUT AS
ARTISTS AND SCIENTISTS KNOW AND
YES, EVEN ACTORS, NOT EVERY
CREATION IS A MASTER PIECE.
OUR NEXT DISCOVERS THE CELLAR
SYSTEM THAT DECIDES WHEN A
SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE PULLED.
TO INTRODUCE THEM WELCOME
YOUTUBE CEO SUSAN AND FOUNDER OF
23 AND ME AND FIVE-TIME OLYMPIC
GOLD MEDALIST SWIMMER KATY
LEDECKY.
>> MY SISTER AND I ARE HONORED
TO STAND HERE WITH THIS
REMARKABLE ATHLETE.
>> AS HER RECORD SHOWS, KATY
KNOWS WHAT IT TAKES TO BECOME A
RACE.
SCIENCE CAN WE COME A RACE BUT
IN THE END EVERYONE WINS.
>> IT'S AN HONOR TO BE STANDING
ON THIS STAGE WITH DOWN TWO
REMARKABLE WOMEN.
AS AN ATHLETE, YOU NEED
COMPETITORS TO BRING IT TO YOU.
THAT MEANS A RIVAL IS CLOSING
AND THAT'S OFTEN WHAT IT TAKES
TO SURPASS YOUR OWN LIMITS.
>> WHICH BRINGS US TO THE NEXT
TWO WINNING SCIENTISTS AND GOLD
MEDAL WORTHY BREAKTHROUGH THAT
THEY SHARE.
THROUGH THEIR RACE TO NEW
DISCOVERIES OVER A DECADE, OUR
NEXT DISCOVERS THE PROCESS OF
THE UNFOLDED PROTEIN RESPONSE.
>> CHAOS.
CHAOS ON THE SCALE.
THERE IS IS CONSTANT MOVEMENT.
RANDOM COLLISIONS BUT SOMEHOW
ORDER COMES OUT OF THIS PROCESS.
MY LAB, WE PRETTY MUCH RUN
PARALLEL IN THIS DISCOVERY, THE
INDEPENDENT DISCOVERY AND SORT
OF MARCH DOWN THE PATH OF
DISCOVERY.
>> COMPETITION MORE SUSPICION
EVEN THOUGH IT IS DEEP,
STRONGER, BIG EYE, MOVING FAST,
EVEN THOUGH OPPONENT LOOK SO
GREAT, JUST GO STRAIGHT.
WE MAKE DISCOVERY OF SYSTEM FROM
OUR BODY.
>> WE DISCOVERED AN ABSOLUTELY
UNIQUE AND UNPREDICTABLE
MECHANISM.
PROTON AS A MACHINE DOES ALL THE
REACTIONS IN A CELL THAT MAKE
LIFE POSSIBLE.
>> MOST OF ITS OWN STRUCTURE.
>> CONSTANTLY CHANGING SHAPES.
THE IDEA IS TO BE IN THE CORRECT
SHAPE TO CARRY OUT THE
FUNCTIONS.
>> PROTEIN.
>> LOOKING INTO THE UNKNOWN,
IT'S SOMETIMES SCARY.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHERE WE'RE PLO
HOW IT WORKS.
>> IT'S VERY DIFFICULT BUT OUR
DNA IS HELIX, DOUBLE HELIX SO IF
YOU KEEP YOUR HEAD GOOD AND UP,
MAYBE IT GO AROUND IN A CIRCLE
SOMETIMES BUT SOME DAY YOU REACH
THE GOAL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR DESCRIBING A FAILURE
QUALITY CONTROL SYSTEM THAT
DETECTS DISEASE-CAUSING UNFOLDED
PROTEINS AND TRIGGERS CORRECTIVE
MEASURE.
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IS
AWARDED TO KAZUTOSHI MORI AND
PETER WALTER.
>> HE ENJOYS BEING AN INSTRUCTOR
USING SWORDS AND PROTECTIVE
ARMOR.
PETER WALTER, A MAN OF SCIENCE
WHEN NOT EXPLORING MOLECULES,
HE'S BUILDING SCULPTURES AS TALL
AS HE IS.
>> I WANTED TO BE PHD SCIENTIST
FROM MY CHILDHOOD.
AT THE BEGINNING, I WANTED TO
START IN POPULAR PHYSICS BUT MET
BIOLOGY BUT WHEN I WAS A FRESH
MAN, I HAD A PERMANENT JOB AS A
BIO CHEMIST BUT AT AGE 30 I
DECIDE TO QUIT THAT JOB AND CAME
TO THE UNITED STATES FOR
MOLECULE BIOLOGY.
IT WASN'T PROMISED SUCCESS BUT I
MET VERY DIFFERENT INTERESTING
PROJECT.
IN DALLAS TEXAS IN 1989, SINCE
THEN I HAVE BEEN BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE, IN JAPANESE, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WHAT AN INCREDIBLE MOMENT.
WE DECIDE FOR THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES OF LIFE AND IT'S
REALLY A FASCINATING JOB TO
FIGURE OUT HOW LIVING CELLS
ACCOMPLISH THEIR TASKS AND IT'S
AMAZING TASKS AND FROM THAT WE
CAN LEARN WHAT IS WRONG IN
DISEASE AND WHAT GOES WRONG AS
WE AGE.
IT CREATES KNOWLEDGE WITH THE
GOAL TO REDUCE HUMAN SUFFERING
AND I REALLY THINK THIS AMAZING
AWARD FOR SHINING THE SPOTLIGHT
ON THE VALUE OF DISCOVERY AND
ALL OF US, ALL OF YOU FOR
JOINING US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WE SEE THE WORLD IN THREE
DIMENSION, UP AND DOWN, RIGHT
AND LEFT, FORWARD AND BACK.
CAN YOU IMAGINE MORE THAN THAT?
THE SURPRISING ANSWER, WHEN WE
COME BACK TO THE BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE.
>>> THE FIRST GREAT QUESTION IS
OF RECEIVED WISDOM WHERE NOT ALL
SCIENTISTS, SOME IN FACT WERE
ARTISTS.
THEY WONDERED HOW TO PAINT
SCENES WITH DEPTH ON A FLAT
CANVASS.
THEY IMAGINE RUNNING SCREENS
THROUGH THE PLAIN OF A PAINTING
TO FIND OUT WHERE THEY MET.
AND THE PROCESS THEY DIDN'T JUST
DISCOVER PERSPECTIVE IN ART,
THEY STARTED A NEW FIELD OF
MATH.
TODAY MATHEMATICIANS HAVE
FOLLOWED THEIR LINES OF LOGIC TO
NEW DIMENSIONS, LITERALLY.
TO INTRODUCE THE WINNERS OF THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IN
MATHEMATICS, IT IS MY PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE A FORMER NFL PLAYER
FOR BALTIMORE RAVINS WHO RETIRED
FROM FOOTBALL TO CONTINUE
PURSUING HIS PHD IN MATHEMATICS
AT M.I.T.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> AND A NEWER SCIENTIST WHO
CO-FOUND -- CONFOUNDED -- WHO
CO-FOUNDED THE AMAZING A.I.
COMPANY.
PLEASE WELCOME JOHN URSCHEL AND
DENNIS.
>> HELLO, I'M THRILLED TO BE
HERE ALONGSIDE MY AFFILIATE.
TO BE HONEST, MY MOM WOULD
PREFER ME TO SKIP THE FOOTBALL
THING AND GO STRAIGHT TO THE PHD
BUT I LOVED EVERY MOMENT OF MY
CAREER AND I'M THANKFUL I DIDN'T
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN MY TWO
PASSIONS.
TO ATHLETES SHORT-LIVED CAREERS
I'D SAY THIS, IT'S NOT TOO LATE
TO START AN ADVENTURE OF THE
MIND AND IN THE SUBJECT LIKE
MATH, THE CHALLENGE IS ENDLESS
BECAUSE THE PLAYING FIELD IS
INFINITE.
>> SAY, JOHN, YOU MIGHT BE
SURPRISED TO HEAR I, TOO, HAD A
SHORT LIVED CAREER AS A CHAMPION
BEFORE MY PHD CHASING GLORY,
SEEING OPPONENTS BUT ENOUGH
ABOUT MY DARK PAST AS A JUNIOR
CHESS PLAYER.
I SHARE JOHN'S PASSION FOR
MATHEMATICS AS A DISCIPLINE IT'S
ENABLED ME TO PROGRAM COMPUTER
GAMES AND BUILD A.I. BUT AN
ARENA OFIITY LIKE
ART, MUSIC AND SPORT AND DOING
SOMETHING BEAUTIFUL PURELY FOR
IT'S OWN SAKE AND OUR NEXT GLOR
ETS DEVOTED THEIR ENTIRE LIFE TO
THAT.
>> RENAISSANCE PAINTERS WORKED
OUT HOW TO SHOW DEPTH.
>> OF COURSE, THAT'S AN
ILLUSION.
IT'S A MAPPING OF A THREE
DIMENSIONAL WORLD.
>> IN MATH THERE ARE DIMENSIONS
HIGHER.
>> THE QUESTION IS HOW TO
REPRESENT HIGHER DIMENSIONS,
FOUR DIMENSIONS AND SO ON USING
THE RULES OF ALGEBRA.
>> I THINK OF DIMENSION AS THE
NUMBER OF DEGREES OF FREEDOM.
>> IF YOU'RE A POINT, THIS IS
NOWHERE TO MOVE.
YOU COULD BE ONE DIMENSION
BACKWARDS AND FORWARDS AND MOVE
IN TWO DIRECTIONS?
WE LIVE IN THREE DIMENSION, FOUR
DIMENSION, COUNT TIME, THAT'S
HOW MANY DEGREES OF FREEDOM WE
HAVE.
THE OBJECTS WE TRY TO STUDY ARE
TYPICALLY SIX DIMENSIONAL OR
HIGHER.
FIND THE PROBLEM WE'RE
INTERESTED AND WE SOLVE IT,
TYPICALLY WITH NOTHING MORE THAN
PEN AND PAPER.
THE PROBLEM THAT JAMES AND I
SOLVED ARE THE FINER GENERATION
POSSIBLY THE CENTRAL PROBLEM OF
OUR RESEARCH AREA.
>> CHRISTOPHER AND I HAD
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES ON THIS
PROBLEM.
>> WE BOTH ATTACK THE PROBLEM
FROM A DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW.
>> IT WAS THE COMBINATION THAT
SOMEHOW WAS THE STEP FORWARD.
>> ONE DAY WE STUMBLED ON A VERY
USEFUL TECHNIQUE THAT WE
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED BECAUSE WE
HAVE COMPLEMENTARY STRENGTH.
>> CHRISTOPHER IS FAR MORE
PRAGMATIC THAN I AM.
>> I'M THE SLAVE DRIVER.
THERE IS A RIGHT ANSWER ONCE YOU
PROVE A THEORY, IT'S TRUE.
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY ABOUT IT.
>> SO I ALWAYS DREAMED OF
SOLVING A PROBLEM LIKE THIS BUT
NEVER THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
REALISTIC.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> TRANSFORMATIONAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO GEOMETRY,
ESPECIALLY THE MINIMAL MODEL
PROGRAM IN ALL DIMENSION.
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IS
AWARDED TO CHRISTOPHER HIRATA.
>> HE LIKES TO CHALLENGE WITH
THE SIX CHILDREN.
>> WOW, WHAT AN INSPIRING
EVENING.
WE'RE TRULY HONORED AND HUMBLED
TO RECEIVE THIS RECOGNITION OF
OUR WORK.
WE HOPE IT WILL INSPIRE OTHERS
TO PURSUE MATHEMATICS AND
PROVIDE GRATITUDE.
WITHOUT MATHEMATIC
CONTRIBUTIONS, WE WOULD NEVER BE
PART OF THE FINISHING TOUCH ON A
DECADES LONG PROGRAM BY DIVISION
AND EFFORTS BY MANY BRILLIANT
MATHEMATICIAN
MATHEMATICIANS.
SHARING THIS PROCESS HAS BEEN
EXHILARATING.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE,
SCIENTISTS CHANGING THE WORLD
WILL RETURN ON NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC.
.
>>> EVERY MOMENT IS A BEGINNING.
EVERY NEW IDEA THAT GROWS CAN
FACE ITS BIRTH TO A STARK OF
INSPIRATION.
AS 2017 COMES TO ITS END, LET US
LOOK FORWARD TO THE BREAK
THROUGHS OF 2018 AND CELEBRATE
THE NEW.
AS WE DO SO, LET US NEVER FORGET
THAT THE SEARCH FOR TRUTH IS
NEVER OVER.
AND THE SURVIVAL OF TRUTH IS
NEVER ASSURED.
WE HAVE TO CHOOSE, DO WE STAND
WITH THOSE WHO WISH TO SUPPRESS
THE TRUTH OR STAND WITH THOSE
WHO SEEK IT?
THE ANSWER IS CLEAR TO ME, TO
US.
AND TO THOSE WHO LOVE KNOWLEDGE
AND WHO WE HONOR TONIGHT, AND
NOW LET US WELCOME BACK TO THE
STAGE THOSE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
QUESTIONING AND SEARCHING FOR
THE TRUTH.
THIS YEAR'S BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE
LAWYERS.
[ APPLAUSE